[Music]
there is no manual on how to be a
lamppost it takes many many years to
learn all the facets of the job at the
peak of the profession there were about
eight hundred lamppost nationally and I
am really one of the last people who are
doing it my name is Jim Woodward and I
am a lamppost that's what I do
[Music]
well lapis is the specialist who works
with lighthouse lenses maintenance of
them moving of them disassembly
reassembly just about everything there
is to do this one I believe is an impact
break when I do an initial inspection of
the lens I will go over every prison and
check every joint literally tap and then
I will do an audio check of every prison
in the lens you can almost play a tune
it requires infinite patience beautiful
just beautiful the lapis profession
started about 1850 so indeed the lapis
work was very important because without
the the lenses being completely
operational they were useless
so the Lancers kept the lenses working
and the lighthouse keepers kept them lit
every night together they kept the
sailors safe
[Music]
as technology was developed the
classical penelon started to decline and
it didn't require the services of
lampposts it would be ashamed to let the
profession die because in the process
eventually the lenses themselves they
died today people drive around the
country looking at lighthouses and think
nothing of it
I almost feel a mystical kind of feeling
when I get there near a lighthouse I
have a real connection to it and I feel
extremely fortunate to have have had a
life fifty-two years now of working with
lenses to me is just the most amazing
thing in the world
you